longtemps réputé comme des enjeux
marginaux la qualité de la vie et
l'environnement font partie intégrante
aujourd'hui de notre société une réalité
pour laquelle une profession est appelée
à jouer un rôle de plus en plus
important celles des architectes
paysagistes déjà grâce à leurs actions
des aménagements ont pu être entrepris
en liaison notamment avec les urbanistes
mais il reste encore beaucoup à faire
pour que le paysagiste puisse s'exprimer
totalement
pour cela il faudrait qu'il soit reconnu
par tous ceux dont le métier influent
sur notre environnement
michel demont clodagh le paysage cadre
de vie de chacun d'entre nous ce qui
touche à notre environnement fait
d'éléments végétal ou minéral
il peut être harmonieux ou non s'il ne
l'est pas apparaissent des conflits qui
jouent moins grave car l'homme ressent
alors à mal de vivre dont les
conséquences sont diverses
les architectes paysagistes sont là
pourtant pour faire respecter cette
qualité de l'espace des exemples
commencent à se multiplier dans notre
région car le paysagiste est de plus en
plus invités à collaborer architecte
paysagiste c'est comme un architecte du
bâtiment sauf c'est l'architecte des
espaces extérieurs
un paysagiste intervient sur l'ensemble
des espaces extérieurs aussi bien sur
les parcs et sur les terrains
or qu'est ce qui te
découverte ils arrivent de toutes les
conceptions organisation de noé pasteur
que ce soit en ville à la campagne
que ce soit en zone urbaine en zone
rurale dans la forêt que ce soit pour
des zones industrielles des zones de
loisirs des lotissements son cadre
d'intervention est très étendu cette
profession n'est pas neuve
il fut une époque où l'homme désirant
dominer la nature pour magnifier son
pouvoir s'attacher les services du
paysagiste c'était un luxe aujourd'hui
la profession s'est démocratisé et ce
médecin la nature joue progressivement
le rôle qui lui revient en étant comme
celui ci est ce qu'on pourrait le conte
sauveur dans une zone industrielle comme
le quartier des tanneurs par exemple le
quartier des tanneurs est une belle
réussite parce que effectivement le
cadre architectural a été soigné et il a
été inséré dans un site qui au départ
était déjà intéressant qui a été
revalorisé par les par l'étude de tous
les aménagements extérieurs est bon je
pense qu'il ya une motivation au départ
intéressante qui était de créer un cadre
de vie qui attire les gens et qui leur
donne envie de s'installer dans des
quartiers comme hautepierre
par exemple est ce que vous pensez qu'il
y aura encore des aménagements à faire
aux pierres oui il ya encore des choses
à faire mais
j'ai eu beaucoup de choses le fait
qu'ils sont positives mais bon il ya
encore des zones qui sont délaissés il
ya encore des réflexions à pousser mais
l'idée de base était bonne
est-ce que les zones piétonnières dans
les grandes villes ou dans les petites
agglomérations
c'est un exemple qui reste à poursuivre
oui je pense disons que dans les petites
agglomérations ne peut pas parler de
zones piétonnes parce que c'est un peu
trop étendue c'est un peu trop
particulariser puisqu'ils n'ont pas des
quartiers suffisamment différent c'est
pour ça mais disons que le fait de
remettre en question la voirie classique
les les systèmes classiques de
conception de voirie est une bonne d'une
bonne chose qui est à continuer la
réhabilitation d'un quartier comme le
neuf
par exemple c'est une bonne expérience
je dis que c'est une expérience
intéressante mais à mon avis qui n'est
peut-être pas parti dans la bonne
direction parce qu'on arrive à des
aménagements très coûteux qui ne sont
peut-être pas en liaison avec la manière
de vivre des habitants mais disons que
la motivation de base était était bonne
heureusement le dialogue avec les
responsables de l'urbanisme et tous les
créateurs de projets à la ville comme à
la campagne s'étend de plus en plus mais
beaucoup de chemin reste à faire surtout
en amont malgré quelques réussites
promarca en france
si le titre d'architecte paysagiste
existe bien il n'est malheureusement pas
reconnu officiellement
un bon point pour la région alsace
pourtant ou ce fait de société qu'est la
valeur de paysages gagne du terrain
oui c'est un fait de société je pense
que c'est un fait société de plus en
plus l'homme avait été limité à une scie
à sa surface à son jardin à son
territoire qui dominait sur lequel ils
se promener pendant les quelques heures
de week-end du samedi dimanche 16 heures
de loisirs et petit à petit avec la
voiture
l'homme s'est déplacé beaucoup plus gros
plus loin et le paysage son jardin c'est
devenu l'ensemble de l'espace perçu
l'espace vu l'espace paysager